like speaking of your kids are they  little big shots they do stuff that  really shocked you and that shocked me a  lot yeah they're they're perfectly weird  and funny I mean Ben and my husband is  like much quieter in malware but he's  super weird I'm not gonna let him off  the hook and our kids are this weird  amalgamation of us and then you really  start to see their own selves come in so  I see me I see met Ben yeah I always  think I'm like if I just don't screw you  up you'll be amazing like if I had it my  way I would stuff them both a baby like  a king or a Porsche or I'm always like  just sit up here and my my oldest is 12  but she's my height now and I'm  literally always like that's just odd  we're in this ain't like I'm wearing  your shoes I don't want to sit on your  lap I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this